siamo io deve vincere deve venire vi
dico ok allora forse vista che questa
che sembra uno spot della tv anni 90 e
li decidiamo nei comitati e sottopassi
ora siamo state ma in ombra bello
dobbiamo fare così per forza perché se
lo devo registrare il web cam a parte
però poi già pieno fa mi sa di più
elegante se non a caldo se invece a
caldo cambio
siamo vicini i signori facciamo tutti
paperini le venuto molto bene allora
siamo solo togliere il mouse però perché
non il mezzo mi dispiace non volevo fare
questo accordo siamo e su ciò che si
chiama e abe o è praticamente per
espressa presa adesso pressa quale sono
io io sono non lo so io sono con la
meglio sull con la sinistra sullo
strappo io sono la domina adesso le
spiego come si giorno me lo ricorda
anche io però volevo giocare in due da
una vita
e poi ecco che siamo già partiti si
aggrappi che deve arrivare al traguardo
capito è capito ho capito come dopo deve
arrivare secondo me però e coop e coppe
da giocare quindi può aggrapparsi a me
venga guardi si lasci unione fa la forza
eccoci tutti i matrimia trattori e io
sono milan se mi lasciava ero finito mi
lasci mi lascia la studiata al peso
no io sono intelligente quello che sa
una più del diavolo è un bellissimo
gioco questo non vedevo l'ora di farlo
in due è pronto sono andati benissimo
allora è un gioco veramente per per
squilla ancora nell'aria non lo sappiamo
perfetto allora non ho mai fatto questa
questo livello io sono quello blu
ragazzi ve lo ripeto il signor gatto e
quello giallo ci si può picchiare avrà
un super sia speciale mi dia una mano
si e poi dopo però c'è un nuovo
cominciata chi su sebbene riguardi
bisogna prendere luogo in ora bisogna
mettere allora porto su io aspettativa
luogo prendo che fa qualcosa ecco a roma
lì
l'amministrazione una distrazione ok non
facciamo così io lei è bravo
guardi non volevo fare volevo fare una
roba che adesso che non è andato a
un'era così diviene forniremo vada vada
a destra scoraggiato per ad arrestare
decisivi all arancio lei si deve
attaccare la smetta di che mi ha preso
male vi deve prendere dalla mano nella
mano che casino mi vedo mi devo liberare
la questa situazione ok limita la mano
la mano lo scatto è stato è ok posto
questo mostro bang consigliamo sui
bilanci di qua bravissimo bellissimo
anomalo che ha lodato mano rende no
bravissimo lazio bravi isola il regolo
con la r
lo controlla ogni volta estero mi sembra
un po cupa mio presente ecco adesso mi
deve lanciare molin l per l'anno dopo
ll molin l como lago tutto io non so che
fare come può essere attaccato con lo
scotch
ok va da un lato si sbilanci è
bravissimo e non è come i calci in culo
deve aggrapparsi in altro rabo no è
troppo verona va bene a me non è in
forma sinistra assist a chi le governa
stacco gravissima vista poi obra r big
blind troppo 2 la bella idea lei è pazzo
però va bene abbiamo capito che la
riunione fa la forza di gioco per un
casino una nota è come facevo bando ma
da sola che mi facevo impossibile da
solo dove lanciare neural
e vabbè allora è così che fanno i veri
problemi c'è un acqua hanno messo lì
perché siamo talmente scarsi che ci
hanno messo qualcosa di capito sopra
anche santana placca non ci arriva e lei
sia per chi lei
l'accordo alla fine va bene lasci ho
paura si lasci siamo come prima se in
alto si lasci ti nato ma non aver niente
a si comprese per loro ho vinto sì
perché ho azzeccato il ricordo
let's dance ma non è detto che chiediamo
almeno in gioco a cui cimini gioco ma
forse perché se non ho mai fatto ma come
onesto perché ormai non ho mai no lo
sbaglio di gruppo è lady gaga quella di
sopra so che la dobbiamo fare quello che
fa lei
passiamo imitatissimi stageup
incredibile e il gioco tempo al governo
era uguale alla palese a vivere la
stretto entrambe sogno perché ci credo
signor gattano avanti questi tutto il
giorno e poi limite di leo qua non mollo
qua c'è dei problemi perché non credo in
antico mito a nessuno sa mai che
giochiamo una vinto lo sport perché noi
giochiamo insieme infatti noi siamo a
porgere a mancava ben a mente e io son
rimasto riconoscibile altre non una
opzione bator ok ma per dire per
iniziare la corda era semplicemente
andare ogni giorno esatte riso che c'è
una cosa da tirare aspetti vista ma se
io arrivo alla fine posso tirare le cose
di si attacca capito è un casino e sam
bravissime siamo bravi dice milioni e
allora quando abbiamo fare quello
bravissimo ha capito tutto ok rialzi ma
lei ha capito tutto e visto già
rivenderle non ho invece non ho capito
lo prenda non renda lei lo fa allora
melo alzo ok vado vado io non ci arrivo
vedeva benedetti mi molli
basta niente ok ho sbagliato lo lanciò
sono pazzo ma guarda che mira
incredibile
e non lo so dove deve alzarsi si alzi la
prendo io venga si molli professa
bravissimi ragazzi è fantastico questo è
stata incredibile doveva l'uomo non lo
prendo effettivamente la prego non ha
nulla da dire sono andato a giugno però
bello rivedere niente ragazzino stanno
vedendo niente perché sotto la webcam
plast che alzo perché con casinò vada
vada lei ma mi scusi magma maser norma
non ci mettiamo d'accordo bozza terry
deve andare lei per comunque se io sono
sotto come vado io e dovrebbero rifonda
qua però per la testa
ok bravo si andrà da p si è capito tipo
bravissimo e si evolve si vuole né
aspetti che non vedo da sempre la
migliore della tribù della trivella e
sono caldissime siamo sopra siamo sopra
vada ma lei non è temerario non possiamo
andare sotto come come fa vada non è
fisica questa cosa aiuto sia gatto si
sapeva era pericoloso per tutti siamo
morti tutti ma come facciamo a tirarci
su dall'impossibile no non si fa si fa
per quelli che richiedono vederci 9
perfettissimo perfetto però adesso in
bocca guardi franzosi possiamo persone e
ma non ci arrendiamo perché mi sono
aggrappato troppo in alto allora faccio
una faccia una faccia nuova palmaria
come se avessi molli nel momento
occupata
ma tu bravissimo sei capi però perfetto
perfetto casa suzuki ormai ma lei è
bravissimo
non avrei potuto desiderare un compagno
migliore gemelli si imbattibili adesso
devo di spostare la webcam tenga ma la
mano la mano aspetti che mi aggrappo ok
simon lee con la pulsione benissimo e no
però devo prendermi aspettano non si
terrà prima reagito così come come come
come modo di arrivare ad un nuovo l'inps
ci sarà lanciato io devo lanciare l'uovo
solo e poi a lanciarmi non ci dobbiamo
cedere tu ma lei è pazzo si fa si fa
allora non c'è file si stia tranquillo
pronto ci è andata male
riguardo pronto si vale non ci credo
sarà fatta era fa sì che ci aveva
ragione lei
pensavo che si potesse fare questa cosa
volevo lanciare proprio luogo e fuori
dopo noi e ci arriviamo
non è ma non è andata bene una frattura
andiamo con meno peggio non so subito
vada vado no ho sbagliato la r sì se poi
a e non c'era la mano però è questo
edificio che non restare in mezzo poi se
veramente difficile
davide giordano facendo lauterstein
secondo me per l aspetto proprio fatto
ok valsi molla si muova a pochi paletti
si venga sud è come faccio ok con tanto
in tanto spirito è stato molto
definizione l'edizione sul 36
niente male ragazzi comunque potestà
mercato invece secondo me dal vivo
rendiamo di più e questo è stato che io
con il signor gatto adesso possiamo
attaccarci perché abbiamo più spazi le
fa male la mano in forma della mano e mi
sudano le ascelle che si legano non ha
fatto neanche tutta quella fatica anzi
facciamo una mamma se non mercato sono
50 euro se mi alzo alle mani così faccio
la copertina
però loro dell'associazione in realtà
non è vero calcio perché così è sembra
meno unito o meglio chi è lei
io sono dati da chiudeva bene shabak
bagni allora si alzi ma non ci stiamo
battendo perché si alza le braccia dopo
il calore che c'è stato fino adesso
mentre eravamo vicini questa che finisce
male non lo faccia possiamo fare va bene
quello prendo c'è un frame di lei che di
lei che tutti imbarazzato così farmi
degli screen gianpi e mandarli tutti sul
telaio
la ringrazio per aver partecipato a
questo video io invito i ragazzi a dare
sul canale le signorie su creditrici del
signor gattolin descrizione e uno
youtube e che ne so magari le proficue
pur i canali del signor gatto che lascia
in descrizione che anche instagram
quello che ho me li gira lei crisi non
faccio che sono pigro noi ci rivediamo a
un prossimo video un bacino
iscrivetevi al canale schiacciatela
campanellina che così li metto
aggiornati sulle nuove uscite e il
telecomando e lì deve averlo non è lei
faccio io a un prossimo video e
schiacciare
[Musica]